I don't know what you're doing per month
but I would not be shocked if this was
doing
between six and eight million a month in
Revenue
blink twice if I'm right
yeah you're uh you guys are pretty you
know on point with your ballpark
[Music]
all right what's up we got Derek from
more plays more dates here I think I
made a fatal mistake before this podcast
I don't know if you know this but um
I was doing research last night I was
like okay I got to be prepped gotta be
ready to go I've been following you for
a while but I said let me just make sure
I I I button up here
and I go to your subreddit r slash more
plates more dates
to be clear this is not like my
subreddit I didn't start right but I
didn't realize this at the time okay so
I'm on this subreddit thinking it's your
subreddit think of these are
just polite civil faithful fans in fact
it says there's 163 000 faithfuls that's
how they call the members uh it is a top
one percent uh subreddit so you're doing
really well and I say hey
I'm interviewing uh Derek Smart he's
coming on a pod we're gonna hang out
what should we talk about
and I said you know give me some ideas
hoping that this you know I did this
like you know let's see a time of post
was like 1am and I go to sleep and I
wake up and I say oh let me just check
that real quick maybe somebody had some
really thoughtful questions
here's the breakdown 98 of them want to
know
um how big your penis is that's the
number one comment by far everybody said
the same exact thing I don't know if
that's an inside joke or you just have
some really really eager fans uh and
then the second was like bro
you needed to know this is a trolling
subreddit this is not a this is not the
serious subreddit of like people trying
to have a real conversation like you
didn't you didn't know what you're
giving yourself into and sure enough I
did not the third comment was bring a
ruler yes
they're very creative I I can imagine uh
what kind of stuff you got had an onslot
of for sure there's a decent amount of
trolling and uh
I don't know just like posting that
goes on there but there is some
insightful stuff like I I'm a moderator
on it I didn't start it but I do check
in time to time and I've been pretty
shocked how much it's ramped up like I
don't know what I don't know what it is
in size but it seems like this is a good
one yeah so Derek what I've been
watching you for years I remember
watching you when you were doing like I
think a cottage cheese or some type of
like protein intake video and you look
horrible because I I believe you are an
amateur or maybe even more serious than
amateur bodybuilder and you're like
cutting and you looked just miserable
when you were like really lean but you
have all these uh amazing videos where
originally it started out as like uh is
this celebrity taking steroids but then
it kind of like expanded beyond that to
like you would actually do some really
cool breakdowns about science the
science behind different Fitness stuff
but then also life advice and uh now you
have like I think four different
companies gorilla mine Merrick and a few
others and so
um we're interested in like definitely
some Fitness stuff but also the fact
that you're running like I think three
or four uh like pretty successful
businesses and what do you have now 1.5
million subscribers 1.8 yeah I think uh
let's see 1.89 yeah yeah so you built
like a pretty like what it appears to be
monster businesses but you've done it
like with some really high integrity it
feels like and you've also uh like your
video setup is like almost janky
although I feel like that's part of the
shtick uh but so it's just like all
about like just really high quality
content that is well researched yeah
it's almost it's quite unintentional the
jankiness because I just don't know what
I'm doing when it comes to uh I don't
know videography and whatnot so every
time I try and Spruce it up it just uh I
failed miserably so I just leave it the
same but I've heard a rumor I've heard a
rumor that you've gotten you know you've
clearly have gotten quite successful I
imagine your businesses are doing tens
of millions in Revenue I heard a rumor
that you've moved to a really nice house
and between your first apartment when
you started and your second better
apartment and your third nice house that
you purposely make the background look
exactly the same to the point of you've
even like took a wall from your first
apartment into the the third place is
that true is this true because we've
been saying this by the way we've been
spreading this rumor whether it's true
or not I heard a rumor from my mouth
okay
first who told you that I I I won't say
I won't uh one of your one of your
friends oh they me over it no I'm
just it's uh it is not a green screen
I'll tell you that
so a lot of people wonder if it is a
green screen it's not some people it
does sound like a real wall that did not
sound like a real wall
it's uh a lot of people use it in their
Zoom calls now apparently which is crazy
they've like pulled the background out
but
um yeah it's uh it's been the same
background for a while it may or may not
be a sauna
um some people you know that's the
prevalent rumor as well but um I think
it's a secret that's gonna live and die
with the channel you also have done a
good job of like somewhat hiding your
identity uh I mean you have to go like
pretty deep in order to find like your
full name
um and you've done a good job of like
kind of staying under the radar while
also being incredibly popular yeah yeah
it's uh I don't know I I don't know how
I even managed to have the foresight to
think of that at the time but it just
seemed like a reasonable idea given if
you were ever going to become popular to
avoid I don't know weirdos and stuff
with that said there's also the you know
question if you're gonna be able to
leave as much of a legacy without your
last name out there but I don't know how
much I believe in that anyways so it
seems like it's worked out the date yeah
I I definitely think it has go go ahead
uh you and your business partner both
have funny like kind of names of your
channels uh your content channels so
your yours is more plates more dates
which is hilarious and then his is I
think goodlookingloser.com yeah yeah he
had like a man's self-improvement blog
from he was an OG YouTuber before I ever
was online he started making content in
2009 I think and that's actually how I
found
his stuff was through his YouTube
channel where he talked about
um you know how to talk to women and he
had like videos of him going up to girls
cold approaching and I was you know
baffled at the time and I was just a
teenager in University watching his
stuff and was one of the first like 10
or 15 people who joined his online forum
and then tracked and logged my I don't
know trials and tribulations with
Fitness and chicks and all that kind of
stuff University and then eventually we
ended up actually working together which
is really cool but um yeah he has not
posted regularly in I don't know five
plus years but he is uh yeah good
looking loser that's the OG right there
and we're going to talk about your your
business side because I I it's unclear
but I believe you built a nine-figure
business so over 100 million dollar
business uh or collection of businesses
off of your channel so uh we'll talk
about the business stuff in a second but
I want to start with with this kind of
pickup thing because I just had Mark
Manson on the podcast the guy who wrote
the subtle art of not giving a a
okay and so he um and he started also
now he's like kind of like all about you
know uh life advice and um you know
self-help and things you know he he's
one of the most popular self-help
authors ever he wrote a book with Will
Smith he's like like super legit now but
he started off in the pickup world and
he had his blog he was named entropy and
his blog was all about picking up uh
picking up women and I've noticed a few
of these backgrounds that seem to lead
to these uh like there's a few
backgrounds like origin stories like a
superhero would have that lead to
interesting people so I've noticed like
Elite Gamers so people are like hardcore
Gamers they tend to become they can
become really successful in the game of
business afterwards if they so choose or
debate debate lends itself very well to
people who end up being you know leaders
you know those types of people because
they're they're they think a certain way
and they're able to articulate
themselves and now another one I'm
noticing is pickup uh and I'm curious if
you think there's anything to that or am
I just reading it to it is there are
there any life skills core life skills
that you really get from that yeah it's
weird I was actually uh I had a lunch
with Andrew Wilkinson a few weeks ago
and he said the same thing about pickup
he thinks that a lot of people come from
that world and I don't know if it's just
like uh uh feeling of inadequacy that
drove you to the pickup stuff to begin
with which also translates to your like
weird drive in an entrepreneurial aspect
that kind of takes you to this level
most people simply won't feel you know
reasonable or something they I don't
know want to strive for but I think
there's definite overlap there and I
don't know if it's like uh emotionally
healthy thing always or a mentally
healthy thing but there's definite
overlap where people are uh I think
trying to optimize all areas of their
life whether it is social dynamics or
what have you and that obviously
translates into business like for me job
interviews became infinitely easier
after I learned how to walk up to
attractive women because if you can walk
up to an attractive you know 10 out of
10 and not get nervous going into a job
interview is just like is butter whereas
before it used to be super nervous you
know you're in the waiting room uh you
know
being extremely I don't know
overthinking the entire situation and
it's to you anything that could be
anxiety inducing is just out of sight
out of mind so for me I think there is a
huge overlap business presentations it
became so much easier became more
confident in rooms meeting new people
whether it was talking to dudes or
talking to chicks didn't matter and um
yeah I think there's still huge upside
not to be like a dirtbag which equates
to being an entrepreneur I wouldn't
suggest that but there are certain uh
social skills and I don't know
like uh EQ you can gain from the pickup
stuff that I think translates Sean you
didn't you didn't study that stuff I I
did yeah yeah because I I read all the
books I I bought some of the courses I
went to like an event before like I was
like really into that because it was
rooted in a sense of like I feel
inadequate and I want to meet women and
like be liked
um but it totally carries over to sales
you know like the rule there's like a
three second there's like a three second
rule it's like as soon as you see a
woman that's like beautiful you have
three seconds to go talk to her or like
there's I mean I use I used all of it I
loved it I wouldn't call myself an
artist though I don't think I made it to
pick up artist it's like a Subway
Sandwich Artist yeah you sure about that
and half half of those guys ended up
like with horrible lives as they got
older like they're like 50 years old and
they're still doing this and it's
like dude that's not cool it's cool to
be settled down actually it's cool to
have like a relationship and so like the
pickup artist Community does a really
good job of teaching young men how to be
confident and meet a woman but then half
of them do a really bad job of saying
all right now here's how you remain
loyal and how you become a good partner
and things like that but they just get
you to the interview or the first day
but they suck after that you know what I
mean it's like horrible how to actually
be a man and treat people respectfully
yeah I think one of the best takeaways
from the pickup artist world is being
able to review their lives from
pre-success being losers essentially to
Peak success having this incredible you
know dating life with diversity and
choice and then what happens to them
thereafter the younger guys have the
luxury to be able to watch the entire
timeline and see did they end up
somewhere that I would aspire to be and
why or why not and how do I avoid
getting down that path because when I
was you know coming up and learning
about this stuff too it was even getting
on a date was a task in itself in an
achievement if you were able to even
muster up a dating life from scratch
with women that were not introduced to
you through your friend circles or
whatever being able to meet people cold
was uh like the floodgates open in terms
of opportunity and
thereafter you know as long as you were
sleeping with women you you thought you
ended the game and you were you know
good to go but you don't realize
thereafter there's a whole nother
element of how do you actually become
happy have successful relationships no
one taught you that stuff so being able
to see the I don't know the before and
after like the Neil strauss's of the
world or whatever and what happened to
them I think is uh pretty insightful I
want to ask you about some of your
businesses and how you're actually
managing all this because you have a lot
going on so there's gorilla mine which
it looks like that's a pre-workout and
creatine you got to tell me what you'd
name it bro I know you hate the name
right yeah
um what was this other one we had we had
this other one called uh what was that
one Sean it was called like deer killer
or something no the deer antler spray
the other one up
well my thing with you Derek is like I
trust you like I trust you a lot and I
buy what you say I totally agree it
reminds me in the same form of like you
remember when we were younger like I
know explode and that stuff and I
remember taking that and I was like this
is awesome and also like this might be
illegal like it was like like it it felt
like like Adderall I was like I got two
hearts right now
[Laughter]
I didn't know anything about it but I'm
like I don't know if this is good but
when I think of your brand I think like
I my values align with your values but
for some reason that I don't think the
name okay let's start with this
objectively this is working right like
I'm looking at the traffic it looks like
it's over a million visitors a month for
an Ecom store that's doing supplements
super high margin uh High review
purchase like I don't know what you're
doing per month but I would not be
shocked if this was doing
between six and eight million a month in
Revenue
blink twice if I'm right
yeah you're uh you guys are pretty you
know on point with your ballparks but
there we go what I will say is
um as far as the niche goes and by the
way that's just like I I don't know if
Amazon is equal to our Shopify but we're
starting to get into retail too and the
traffic numbers are oftentimes quite
misleading so I don't know what you guys
used for that but I've
start I don't know if how much I read
into those traffic statistics you
similar web or what do you what do you
yeah this I was looking at similar but I
have like I have like layers it's like
you can go like quick look at traffic
then it's like there's tools that will
literally just tell you here's the sales
at the store but it doesn't know what
your wholesale and Retail might be but
you're like all right I know if they're
if their Shopify is at this level and I
know that they have some retail
distribution you can get pretty pretty
close right yeah so as far as The
Branding around it
um I do agree in the health Niche when
it comes to trusted dietary supplements
for I don't know let's just say a
multivitamin or a B complex or a lipid
support product those kinds of things I
am totally on the same page that even I
wouldn't necessarily have the highest
trust factor in a company called a
gorilla bind or a bucked up or whatever
when it comes to things that are meant
to
get you cognitively dialed in though and
things that are meant to be hardcore
pre-workouts and vasodilate the out
of you all this kind of stuff that is
where the more edgy branding I think for
example the same way you wouldn't trust
a gorilla mine B complex and you would
go with a thorn you probably would go
with a gorilla mode pre-workout over
Thorns pre-workout
probably I think most people would it
depends who's buying it like I'm like a
30-something Yuppie guy who doesn't I'd
like I want to look good naked and I
want to live a long time and there's
like a balance of like what what you
know am I putting like bro in my
body or am I kidding do you know what I
mean but then like your other one
Merrick health I'm on that website uh I
invested in this company called hone I
think Sean maybe did too uh I think you
in my opinion The Branding of Merrick is
like beautiful I think that's
beautifully done what so Merrick help
does like hormone optimization or
hormone replacement therapy you do a
bunch of thyroid stuff I think that
branding is phenomenal and I would guess
that this company will be more valuable
than gorilla mine because it's I I would
imagine it's a subscription
um and it's probably what like 300 a
month on average per customer yeah and
the telemed especially in high level
preventative medicine diagnostic space
you are
um it's a lot more premium for sure and
the margins are superior but it's also
contingent on the level of service and
that's where we differentiate ourselves
there's a lot of telemedicine pop-up
clinics now and hormone replacement
therapy you know spots to go to and we
try to steer away from that moniker we
are kind of like uh I don't know it's it
it's uh
broad spectrum preventative medicine
whereby you can trust that you're not
going to just get thrown on a cookie
cutter script of testosterone and
astrozole and get kicked out of the door
like we pride ourselves on the services
and the doctor oversight and the quality
of care and the providers especially are
highly educated and are vetted by me and
my team specifically so it's not it's I
would say more than 300 bucks a month
for sure in general
um but that is definitely uh the way of
the future in terms of what I am most
passionate about and yeah you're
definitely right that it's I would say
at least objectively right now perhaps
more valuable than gorilla mind are you
um who are you how big is your your team
now um and who do you have helping you
run each of these companies because
that's a it's fairly complex I imagine
yeah maybe breaking down like your core
team that's like not assigned to any one
of these companies and then like what
does a core team look like first and
then how do the sub companies look yeah
so fortunately from an operational Nolan
backhand standpoint I live in Canada by
the way the companies were based in the
U.S so for me being on site is
essentially impossible so I have my
business partner Chris good looking
loser is in Idaho where the role of Mind
HQ was stationed and he's the one who
built out the team in person for
warehouse fulfillment
um we will both be ones who vet out the
high level c-suite guys but a lot of the
more uh
um I don't know like Hands-On tasks are
going to be fulfilled through teams
there that I have minimal
um oversight or interaction with I'm
more of the marketing and c-suite level
stuff and Retail a bit now but that is
in terms of the team and number of
people I think there's like 50 to 100 in
each company but I don't I don't
actually know to be honest but as far as
oversight from gorilla that
typically that's essentially how it
works is we have Chris in Boise me in
Canada I oversee all things marketing
content product formulation
manufacturing supply chain
he oversees everything Hands-On
fulfillment warehouse distribution
um legal accounting uh and obviously
there's some teams within that that we
oversee essentially and we have you know
Financial controller we have like a guy
overseas retail et cetera et cetera but
that is kind of how the org chart would
delineate out and then on the Merrick
Health side uh my business partner he's
not he doesn't have an online presence
but he's somebody who I met through the
industry myself years ago and he's
um exceptionally well versed in how to
operate a team and build out the
infrastructure and get the licensing and
everything necessary to be above board
and stay on top of all the compliance
stuff because in the telemedicine space
it's you know quite a bit goes into
making sure you're doing it the right
way because there are a lot of clinics
that get spun up and essentially are
just illegally prescribing steroids
essentially that is literally why they
exist more or less and a lot of
compounding pharmacies despite being
legitimate compounding pharmacies are
not above board either and they will
prescribe underground lab level drugs
that are not even pharmaceutical grade
it's wild stuff so
um he oversees essentially everything
when it comes to the team the uh I will
help vet out the providers and high
level talent and c-suite guys and
whatnot and I'm also heavily involved in
marketing similar to gorilla but he is
uh without the my partners none of this
would be possible and then his
intelligent shop like around it is that
the third one
um is that the third major one or those
two significant yeah oh I would say
those two are definitely bigger than
intelligent but intelligent has uh
uh probably the best profit margin I
would say but that company is me and
Chris as well what's crazy is that like
you're going You're like doing more
challenging problems so like I I have no
idea how challenging a supplement
company is but let's just say that
that's like a two or three out of ten
and then uh Merrick Health would be like
a six or seven out of ten or even higher
because there's like actually starting
to do with like regulation and then I
know that you I think you said it here
and you said it on videos you're
thinking about doing a compound pharmacy
which it like for the which sounds like
the hardest and like I I don't know too
much about it but does that basically
mean like you're actually getting the
Commodities from whoever you're getting
and you have to make sure they're safe
and that you're handling them safely and
I guess compounding means you're
combining uh and shipping them out to
the Merrick health of the world is that
right yeah so for example when you get
prescribed your testosterone for example
from a clinic like americ health or
maybe the own I'm not sure how they
operate but in general they will fill a
prescription through a pharmacy like an
Empower or a fill in the blank
compounding pharmacy that is also having
their own markup on medication is the
ones receiving the active drugs and
creating a finished product for you to
prescribe and just logically anytime you
can try and get more of the supply chain
to control the margin that's going to be
beneficial I would imagine at at which
point it becomes a logical and
worthwhile
use of your time though is to be
determined because similar to the
manufacturing side on dietary
supplements although there's different
levels of quality control and oversight
you know you still have to be GMP
certified and you know have a certain uh
level of oversight in your facility and
is the bandwidth allocated to
doing that taking away from your what
your bread and butter is on the private
labeling or marketing side of things
depends on the person I guess because
some companies kill it just being
manufacturers and not even having a
company that they sell stuff through so
empowers the guys that a lot of people
go to I believe right how big do you
think that business is 100 million plus
probably what what could that be worth
what would like what would a multiple in
that business be I don't even know what
those would sell for because is that
considered just a manufacturing business
well it's tough because they definitely
have some level of trust factor that
other pharmacies don't have for even for
me if I was to get a compounded
testosterone from Empower versus from
some Rinky Dink compounding pharmacy I
would 100 trust in power more than fill
in the blank even though they have
supposedly you know same levels of
quality control rigor licensing Etc
um there is pretty significant
variability sometimes in the compounding
world plus minus on so certain drugs
even as shocking as that sounds what you
see on the label even in the
pharmaceutical world is not always what
you're getting in compounding that just
seems like such an intimidating business
to go down down the path yeah
fortunately for me and that it's
something that it's it's actually wild
because Guerrilla mine is probably the
thing that has the highest level of
difficulty for me because I'm intimately
involved in product formulation whereas
on the telemed side fortunately there is
no need for me to I don't sit there
making
medication formulations you have a
preset you know testosterone
concentration or fill in the blank drug
I don't control all that or need any
creativity or insight into what goes
into that because it's a very tightly
regulated
thing whereas in the supplement world
people will just look at our label and
rip us off often so I am often the guy
who has to be creative come up with
innovative ideas and I don't want
somebody to come out with my name on it
that I don't have significant you know
personal time investment into that
formula that goes out so you know for me
the Guerrilla mind formulation and
product rollout side of things is the
most time consuming so I would say
gorilla is like six or seven out of ten
and America's you know like a two out of
ten for me oh interestingly yeah we had
um Doug tomorrow on do you know who Doug
tomorrow is he's a car YouTuber yeah
yeah he's awesome he's cool he um you
know built this thing up to like four or
five million subscribers then he
launched this thing cars and bids which
uh he sold a portion of the business
um and cars and bids could be a multi
hundred million dollar business I think
I think it's awesome and um but like
going to to compare you to him that
would be like him starting to make like
car parts and I'm like dude Doug why
don't you just like make the best car
make it Marketplace ever yeah just like
Crush that because like if I think of
like you Derek launching uh and I don't
know much about the space when I think
about you launching like a pharmacy I'm
like uh man that seems like you're
leveraging yourself pretty high like
what if that everything up like as
opposed to kicking ass at these other
two things I'm not dead set on it so I
imagine during
uh I don't know Discovery if I'm buying
a company or just the process of
fleshing out all the details I will
probably uncover that
you know leaning into our bread and
butter is probably more worthwhile so
despite it being on my radar similarly
to the manufacturing side of supplements
or energy drinks it's probably not worth
our time or money right now so you know
to be determined in the future there's
one reason why I imagine you should do
it which is It's pretty dope like you
know like there's still like there's
still like that component of like this
seems it very challenging but like this
would be sick if you could actually pull
it off you know what I mean like there
is that factor of like it is it's you
know entrepreneurships are and that
that's a cool challenge yeah no it's uh
and just be able to control everything I
think there's
you're not putting yourself in a
position where you can get squeezed
whereas companies like Roman they have
their own pharmacies and there's a
reason why you know they're not gonna
just private label to hell and Market
the out of it they're going to
control the drugs so you know to me it
seems like at scale there's some
inevitable Obstacle of trying to control
that aspect of the business and not
being subject to whatever the you know
drug makers decide for you but to be
determined on that do you uh like what's
your business goal so like uh you
shifted your focus you're like okay I
went to this bodybuilder
dating like number one priority that
you're like all right making money
entrepreneurship became the main focus
for like the last period of time last
season
um what's your business goal because
we've met a bunch of people that are
like some of them take this like
oh shucks I don't know I'm just trying
to you know help people like type of
attitude which I rarely believe to be
honest
um and then there's a lot other people
like Rob Dyrdek came on and he's like
dude I was like yeah I was like a
skateboard kid then ended up doing this
this I ended up on TV still wasn't
making any money and I finally realized
like oh like in the last like in this
last like five year period I figured out
like
okay I need to go from Rookie white belt
to black belt and I made it my focus I
made it my goal and I said I wanted to
make a billion dollars and I decided all
right to do that what do I need to do I
need to own my own production company
instead of just being a talent so now
I'm the talent and the production
company and then I brought people in and
I started investing I own real estate
and I he CR and he like was very
articulate about it and our audience
loved it because they were like dude I
had no idea he actually kind of had that
part of his brain that had like
intentionally set a goal and made a plan
and started figuring it out
what's how would I describe it for you
what's your you know because you started
off just doing this kind of fun I think
the business news came up you know about
what what's your goals and how did that
come about
um yeah I should probably revisit my
goals because I don't really have a firm
concrete uh objective I do know from a
value standpoint I think gorilla mine
and Merrick health or billion dollar
companies in the future at some point
and I do uh very much intend for them to
get there and I strongly believe they
will I mean that that sounds like a good
goal I mean I mean if I was to put
something on paper as a financial metric
of sorts those would be you know two
concrete ones I could say in my near
near ish future I foresee as
um doable and I want to make sure it
happen but it's I don't I don't
necessarily want to sell them either
it's just kind of a vanity metric or
something that you're chasing almost
like a million subscribers on YouTube
once you get there you know it's the
same old the next day nothing changes
other than your objective success
and how you feel about yourself to some
extent maybe and how people perceive you
but and maybe you have more flexibility
in what you can do but you know that's
kind of how I see it too is
once the businesses businesses get to a
certain point it's just going to be more
of the same
um probably I don't know I I can't
imagine there's like especially from the
miracle side of things it's a company
that I'm so passionate about
preventative medicine if something is
working that is literally me being able
to at scale educate and import value
about that it's hard to see me deviating
from it to be able to do what that again
it doesn't really
I don't know maybe I'll change my
mindset as I get a bit older and I have
kids or something but right now not
really uh that that's kind of all I
could say as far as concrete goals on a
piece of paper financially and also my
path in terms of what I'm passionate
about have you raised financing or
funding for any of these businesses no
never dude that's crazy because like all
right you have 1.8 1.8 million
subscribers 1.9 close to 2 million
that's a lot but that's not a lot a lot
you know what I'm saying I mean that
that's like if someone grinds for 10
years like you could get there what's
crazy is that
do I mean that's just a huge number to
have two multi-billion dollar or two
let's just even say 100 million plus
Brands off the back of 1.9 million
subscribers that's a significant amount
oh yeah you have to keep in mind to our
influencer marketing is pretty dialed
especially on the gorilla side and we
have a lot of people who believe in what
I'm doing and my passion and path
forward too and trust me so they will
also trust that I'm going to put them in
the best spot to accrue the most value
from whatever company they're partnering
with and have mutually beneficial
relationships as they develop their
business careers too so especially on
gorilla there is no way we'd be anywhere
near where we are well I don't know what
we'd actually be at but a lot of our
influencers behind us are huge needle
movers huge like I would say our
combined following is like I don't know
in the tens of millions if not 100
million plus is it contention you
getting more popular do you think or do
you think that they've grown beyond that
yeah I think they're big enough they can
be their own thing and I think
fortunately for me
uh it has allowed me the flexibility to
reel back on the content frequency a bit
because I used to be very heavily output
oriented which I should be still but
the trust factor is very high and the
success of the company stands has it has
its own I don't know resume of
credibility through what it's done like
being I don't know one of the top
selling pre-workouts on Amazon for
example against companies I literally
bought when I was 17 years old and
edging some of them out now like that's
wild to me and those kind of things help
us get into retail and help us do things
from a global expansion standpoint that
aren't contingent on me sure it helps
that I'm a face of the brand and what
I've done and you know that when you
work with us I'm going to be the one
formulating your products too for
example like when influencers work with
us if you're gonna have a collaborative
pre-workout that drops knowing that I'm
indirectly endorsing it and making it
for you too is a huge plus whereas most
owners are not even faces of the brand
and no one even knows who they are so
that kind of stuff I think gives us the
latitude and flexibility to grow moving
forward outside of having this
influencer treadmill where we're having
to acquire new people to get exposure to
then sell more I think there is
absolutely a diminishing returns point
and for us at this point it's very uh
Global expansion oriented in retail
going heavier into retail on some of the
uh some of the products like the energy
drinks and whatnot but
um to be determined so it's all a bit of
an experiment to be honest
I went I went and read your blog and uh
prepped for this and I read a bunch of
bunch of the posts and you said
something you said when I was 18 what
were my priorities you said well I
wanted to make more money I wanted to
date hordes of gorgeous women I want to
have a killer physique and I wanted to
do well in school to set me up for my
future and you said you know I had these
four goals and those all sounded like
totally worth pursuing and they all
sounded like things I should be working
on I'm in school so I should probably
work on school I'm I'm kind of you know
18 to 21 years old I should probably try
to date women or work out
um make money all of these things seemed
like good ideas at the same time and
then you realized
I should go all in on one of these goals
right now at the expense of the others
why did you have that philosophy of go
all in on one life goal versus try to
have kind of this balance or pursue all
four
uh yeah stuff because it's not like I
would claim it to be the correct way to
live your life but I think a lot of
people live especially in the
entrepreneurial World in stages it's
almost like seasons of your life and
there are certain Seasons where you can
complete certain things are
prerequisites for the other
um and I would say that when it comes to
um getting women for example when you
were young you do not need exorbitant
amounts of funds you actually don't even
need to have the ability to support
somebody in a long-term relationship if
you're young you can have a piece of
crap car and live with your parents and
still crush it with literally like
objectively 10 out of 10 girls in your
age bracket and being able to kind of
get that season of your life out of the
way and develop those social skills at
least at the time when I was broke too I
felt like was worth getting out of my
way so to speak before I went down the
road of
entrepreneurship which I knew would
consume the majority of my free time and
dating especially
large amounts of women when you're
trying to kind of I don't know get your
anxiety out of your system entirely and
become even used to this Dynamic of
being out with attractive women
um it's not something that I feel you
can juggle both simultaneously dating as
a full-time job honestly like if you're
single you can definitely agree with
what I'm saying that it can be as
consuming as a full-time job in itself
so for me you know trying to and I also
was way more hardcore about bodybuilding
at the time so I would actually dedicate
blocks of time to cutting and bulking
phases and The Cutting phases would be
getting Striking Distance of stage ready
condition which is something that is
super mentally sapping and demanding of
your body and more extreme amounts of
cardio caloric restriction Etc and
it's not trying to do everything at the
same time I feel like you'll just
fail or do everything kind of half-assed
essentially you will not get anything
done with exceptional quality so that
was at least my thought process and
logic at the time and I would still
probably agree with it even though that
blog is I don't even remember the last
time I wrote an article on that blog it
is super outdated but it is something I
would still
um resonate with probably I think people
should be segregating things into
Seasons personally yeah I mean we talk
about Seasons a lot and um I think like
what's that quote uh Sean about the line
and the cow like cows Grays lines rest
and then pounce and uh like oftentimes
it's a little bit easier in business to
be like the line instead of just like
you know uh for instead of like a
constant 40 hours a week maybe like
Sprints is is a little bit easier
um and I was watching some of your
videos I remember there was one recently
where I think you got back from Europe
you're in Europe and it sounded like
you're with a girlfriend or a wife or
something like that
um so I assume you're in some type of
long relationship has building these
companies been a lot easier once you're
you have more stability as opposed to
dating yeah dude it's uh night and day
try if I was single right now I would
get half as much work done probably yeah
yeah dude haven't and like I I remember
when I was building my first company
um there was probably twice a week I
would lay on the floor
and I'm like this isn't gonna work I
feel miserable uh like I'm just gonna
quit and like having a spouse or she was
my fiance or girlfriend at the time to
be like no you got this like that is
just like it was like the greatest thing
ever that's when I knew I'm like dude
having a a wife is so much better than
she's like also move out of the way I'm
trying to get to the kitchen
[Laughter]
oh yeah I would I I yeah I totally agree
with that sentiment for sure
[Music]
oh
CRM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases HubSpot grow better
have you figured out what you want to do
with your money so do you uh have you
learned kind of like you know how to
either spend it in ways that are
interesting or invest it uh how much
time and effort have you put into that
like what do you do with your money I've
learned what not to do with it which is
good what have you done what have you
done
so
um don't go with wealth management
portfolio uh guys who will even if it's
with a big bank because they get their
management fees even if they suck so and
oftentimes they will
make it sound like they're doing great
things when objectively they're
underperforming a basic you know Index
Fund so I would be very weary of that as
a wealthy entrepreneur because a lot of
those guys are the primary targets of
those you know wealth management guys
and they will shockingly stay with them
for years despite underperforming just
objectively and then you know they just
get uh get rinsed the entire time while
the management fees make the other guys
rich so I've learned not to do that the
hard way
um the thing that's tough is on the
Canadian side there is so much more
complicated tax planning that goes into
it I've spent more time than I want to
admit on figuring out how to not lose
money than actually like making money
with my money so
um it's tough yeah like I'm still
figuring even figuring out how to put
myself in the position most optimally to
make my money work for me but oftentimes
even knowing what side of the country I
should be keeping it on
it's it's been a ever learning process
and there are certain corporate
structure things that I've been very
hesitant to pour money into you know uh
Insurance Fund that down the line is
going to build money interest free and I
can then re I've been very careful to
not dive into any of those before I
fully understand them even though they
could make me a lot of money because I
know once you're into some of those
things you can't unravel them so you
know as a Canadian it's a lot more
complicated unfortunately than just
dollar cost average into the index so if
you're if your portfolio you know let's
just say you're you know we'll do the
pie chart thing without so just
percentages and not including your
private businesses where do you where do
you keep your money is it mostly
equities are you investing uh in other
private companies what are you doing
with it
um I do some Angel Investing but it's
very minor like for example media kits
you guys are familiar with cure and
that's how we met like his company for
example I invested in
um I know some some stuff like that but
not very often uh
but primarily it was you know wealth
management was overseeing a lot of it
and then I realized how not ideal that
was and liquidated it all recently at a
loss but um yeah it's just sitting in
bank accounts right now doing nothing no
really yeah yeah so I'm like all
cast right now I have a decent amount of
crypto but I always forget I have that
until somebody asked me like what is
your portfolio comprised of so I guess
technically some crypto
um and then I guess it's the value of
the businesses and whatever cash sits in
those accounts but yeah it's uh mostly
just just chilling doing nothing useful
I remember you you I think you bought a
Lamborghini or something like that and
you like made a video about like the
hidden on it or uh hedonistic treadmill
and you're like this is kind of
is there any what what have you spent
money on that you think is that would
make you happy and it was
versus where you actually like where do
you like to spend money on and you're
like this actually makes me happy
that's tough man because I don't other
than that I haven't really spent
egregious amounts of money on anything
that I would deem to be irresponsible
that was outside of a business capacity
like I will invent you know
always go first class because of the
convenience and just leg room and just
like basic stuff which is
um and other than that I don't really
buy anything luxury other than groceries
which you know getting high quality food
I think is Justified every single time
um yeah I haven't really spent money on
anything I can think of off the top of
my head that was stupid what uh what was
the origin story for the business so
what what order do they come in and uh
what triggered the thought of like all
right I need to
um I need to start this because I think
you kind of you're in an internet
marketing affiliate game
um when did you transition to like I
want to own my own businesses yeah
especially prior to influencer
Integrations when I first started
affiliate marketing it was still very
SEO driven blog heavy there was not as
much uh flat rate you know paper
integration type stuff happening or at
least I was not that aware of it if it
was happening at scale what were you
selling oh an array of things whatever I
use personally Amazon links to it Etc so
I was getting you know five percent
commissions on shampoo that I would use
for hair loss prevention or and was that
like beer money or that was like like
wow I'm making stupid money doing this
somehow like how how successful were you
able to be doing that well I guess
success is definitely subjective so at
the time I felt extremely but you know
in proportional terms perhaps not now
but back then that was the stuff that
funds your ability to actually start
your own businesses so I would say in
that sentiment definitely successful and
I think the thing that helped me the
most and what I typically recommend
people to do is when they're wondering
what do I even get into as a product or
service or what have you
it's organically integrating things that
you already use and truly believe in
because if you just plug nonsense and
you start to be a ad Homer essentially
where you just take whatever comes your
way when it comes to Integrations even
products you don't believe in or care
about and you just become a robot
mindlessly reading scripts for you know
dollars you're kind of get your
credibility goes out the window and
people don't listen to your product
recommendations anymore and for me it
was always how do I monetize stuff that
I use anyways and would tell people for
free
you should use this because I use it so
oftentimes that was taking piddly little
affiliate commissions or none on
products that I actually used and wanted
people to also try to get results with
and that would include but not limited
to you know supplements hair loss
prevention products
um sometimes random diet hack related
things I don't know it varied
significantly but across the board it
was basically what has an affiliate
program that is a product I already use
and I can get a commission for telling
people something I would tell them
anyways and that is how I kind of built
up my initial funds to then start some
of the businesses that replaced the
affiliate recommendations that I would
have been making anyway so it's it was
kind of stemmed from just what are the
things I'm most passionate about
personally and promote them and because
I would anyways and then replace them
eventually with things that I feel are
higher quality and reflect
exactly what I would want to see as a
consumer in that Niche so that's kind of
how I went down the rabbit hole of
dietary supplements I've always been a
formulator
um I've always dug very heavily into the
chemistry and pharmacology side of
things and it was just an eventual
inevitability that I was going to get
into it at some point and once I became
viable financially that was kind of my
segue into that and then hair loss
prevention products I've been
recommending certain things for years
and that was my segue into uh
intelligent elephant which is another
company and then telemedicine was
I was making content for years about
preventative medicine and how to
interpret Diagnostics and blood work and
hormone optimization and Peds ergogenic
AIDS Etc and it was that was such a
no-brainer for me to get into too so
um across the board that's kind of what
I look for as the highest level
opportunities uh at least how I kind of
ended up starting those businesses to
begin with and funding them we had our
buddy Syed on and what he did was he had
a high traffic blog that was helping
people out with WordPress he's like oh
yeah I recommend using this email pop-up
and like he would just basically see oh
okay you know the highest the things
that people click on the most because
they're looking for a solution are X
maybe that's a business I should go into
it's what he would do is he would just
go buy that business or buy the number
two player improve it and then make it
his recommendation and he just went
systematically it's almost like you've
did that for the body uh you were like
cool I got this high traffic and I give
this ability to get a bunch of high
traffic
I can start with Affiliates and see what
people click what you know even if they
have a crappy affiliate program at least
I know that's a category that I know I
can drive a lot of a lot of customers to
maybe I should be the supplier instead
of the affiliate yeah it's crazy how
much stuff has evolved just in the past
I don't know not even 10 like six or
seven years too in terms of where people
get their recommendations from like SEO
is
so irrelevant now to where I shop and
where most of our customers shop too
back in the day it was if you're top
ranked on Google maybe for some Services
is absolutely still relevant but for
certain products and e-commerce space
and whatnot it's like no one gives a
at all whereas back in the day if
you it was all about how do I get top
ranked on Google for buy fill in the
blank or top three fill in the blank and
that was uh a lot of my affiliate stuff
came through my blog articles back then
and lesser YouTube but now it's so
heavily social media the New York Times
had this article come out a few weeks
ago and it was like my Guru is better
than your Guru or something like that
and it was about how I mean this has
always been the case but it's just
there's more now and they're bigger
about how audiences will attract well
we'll go towards a certain like health
and wellness person so like there's you
there's huberman but then there's also
um uh Mark Sisson is that the same Mark
the the the older guy who started a
primal kitchen and then there's like
five or six or ten or Twenty other ones
and they actually but the the article
was saying and this is true that they
say different things like that not
everyone agrees so there's like you know
eat a lot of plants but then there's
like carnivore MD and then you you know
you did your whole thing on uh the liver
King like they don't they they
oftentimes will say like different stuff
but you just get behind someone and you
just do whatever they say like if you go
if you talk to Andrew huberman like the
most common question he gets and I'm
sure you get this too which is just tell
me exactly what you do and I'm gonna do
the exact same thing yeah uh you know
what I mean but and that's in one hand
that's on one hand that's maybe
dangerous because it doesn't always
apply to each person but on the other
hand it makes a great ass business
because it's just like whatever Derek
says I do and I buy and I think that
you've had like videos where you're like
my supplement company like I'm not going
to just make a ton of product because I
have to make the quality good but you
guys are buying so much of it that we
need like two weeks off in order to
restock uh you know what I mean so it's
like good for you as a business owner
yeah I think uh trust factor is
everything nowadays especially because
there is so especially in the health
Niche it is so hard to know who to trust
because oftentimes the charlatans will
get platformed too because they say
outrageous things but you'll see them on
big podcasts even sometimes just because
they'll say something that seems so
contradictory to what is
accepted as you know scientific fact or
whatever just to get a good hook not
even necessarily because they're The
Authority or foremost expert in a
certain area and it's super confusing
for the Layman who was just trying to
you know learn something and then they
hear 17 different versions of
recommendations for something that
should be basic and yeah trying to even
what I do too and I think a lot of
people should do when they're
self-educating is find a you know
handful of people that through all
evidence provided are have highest trust
factor and
knowledge simultaneously because the two
coupled or what are going to lead you to
what I feel to be actual recommendations
that are practical and
um valuable rather than just you know
fall it's wild how many you know bad uh
Educators there are out there for sure
and how did you become an expert like uh
you know huberman's like a professor at
wherever it's like it's like a Stanford
lab or something
um
you know you when I first saw your thing
you're like oh I I think I was clicking
like some of the videos that were like
what is Conor McGregor taking or Jon
Jones or whatever
and you're talking about the pulsing
effects of picograms of whatever that
Jon Jones got popped for
and I was like how the hell would this
guy know it doesn't even seem like usada
even understands like what the hell is
going on like where is the literature of
this how would this random YouTuber
know about any of this stuff
um largely through years of
self-education but also through
educating myself through experts and
being I feel I'm very good at
extrapolating out
and determining what is valuable
information and then assimilating it
into my own Consolidated framework
that's one of my strong uh strong suits
so it's taken years I've been
researching like a maniac since I was I
don't know like 10 10 plus years at this
point so for me uh I don't necessarily
claim to be an expert oftentimes people
will you know label me as such but
um you know I'm just a guy who's a nerd
and learns a lot of and it's been
uh it's been good to date but yeah a lot
of this stuff is available though too
it's just hard to translate into
layman's terms like somebody who's in
the lab
determining if an assay is going to be
implementable for the usata in the
future to catch people doing fill in the
blank
that you said uh I don't know
spokespeople don't necessarily
understand the chemistry and the science
they're not going to go out and go into
elaborate detail about why you could
still get away with micro dosing for
example like that kind of nor was it
beneficial for them to assert publicly
that it's possible to do such so a lot
of this stuff is just swept under the
rug and no one talks about it because
they either don't understand it or it's
not very I don't know readily circulated
so but it's all publicly available it's
just a matter of being able to dissect
it so you know that's kind of been it
what do you think of the uh the sort of
the tech tech uh testosterone movement
that's going on so you got Bezos retires
gets jacked you got Zuck becoming an MMA
fighter you have
um who else is who else is doing it
there's a couple of Brian Johnson uh he
logs on semi glute side so he's at least
trying to get ripped not necessarily
sauce to the gills but he's trying to
get you know lose weight
yeah what do you think of uh what do you
think who's doing it right who's doing
it wrong what do you what do you see in
the uh Tech uh Tech bodies I think it's
uh good that guys are prioritizing
muscle mass and quality of life and
whatnot over just you know
existing so I think it's an overall good
thing to have
um I don't know be pursuing kind of
the masculine type and I don't know path
but
I don't necessarily know who's doing it
wrong or right because they're not very
outspoken about their protocols and what
about Brian Johnson because he's
meticulous about like you know
publishing what he's doing what what's
your take on it on what he's doing that
guy it's tough because I do see the
value in what he's doing but I think a
lot of it is totally contradictory like
for example the guy will calorie deprive
the hell of himself to the point of
having hormone suppression but then a
supplement with testosterone it's like
dude make up your mind hey which which
one is going to be conducive to
longevity verse not because you're kind
of just correcting what you screwed
yourself up for to begin with so why why
is your body trying to fight back
against you just to you know manually
administer something to correct your
deficiency self-induced from literal
nutrient deprivation like that there's
clearly some sort of uh I don't know
contradictory
uh actions in this protocol in my
opinion but overall I think it's
interesting for sure see what he thinks
is impactful versus not but as you start
to roll out some of the the products and
services related to his stuff you start
to wonder you know how much of it is
just you know Noble intentions versus
you know the entrepreneurial you know
aspect of it which is fine but it's like
do not if it goes down that road where
he goes heavy into selling
I really hope he is very candid about
his uh desire to monetize and not make
it seem like this Noble you know thing
entirely because it's certainly not you
know your private label olive oil like
other people could have got it you could
have just recommended a good company you
didn't have to go do it yourself
necessarily
you know you use some other companies up
until a certain point why not just talk
about them and give them the business
there's there's some sort of monetary
incentive there which is fine
um I think a lot of the stuff he does is
way Overkill and I think it's kind of
hard to track anything with any relative
certainty when there's a billion
different variables and I also think he
puts way too much Credence into certain
trackers like the the age clocks
those are complete essentially
and I don't think uh it's of great
utility to be tracking those
meticulously as if that's reflective of
exactly what's going on and what why are
the age clocks that I would
need to dig into more but a lot of it is
based on your current what is going on
in your body in this current snapshot of
time and then trying to reflect okay
your
uh velocity of Aging equals this because
you had a transient like better blood
sugar or fill in the black biomarker you
could just as easily screw up your blood
work and make it look like you're way
older than you are in a matter of days
so it's like obviously your
chronological biological age didn't
shift that much in a matter of days but
just based on your current health status
in your blood in your body right now you
can make it look like you're plus minus
20 years so to actually take that and
make it assert that oh this is uh it
equals I'm this young now it's like no
you're maybe your current snapshot in
time reflects something that looks like
that but it is not indicative that that
is your overall health status so I would
have to do I probably should do a video
on it at some point but it's uh most
credible people that I trust
think it's personally I test
all of them so I've done uh inside I
think inside tracker or Insight tracker
and then uh true Diagnostics and then
like I've done all of them they're
they're it's messed up because I know in
my head that this is theory and that
it's a it's most like I know it's a
gimmick but it's so fun you know what I
mean they come out the same Sam when you
try it across multiple Services yeah
those two came out the same which was
basically like my blood work is great
and um I think they give you actually a
number so they're like you're 34
biologically you're 23 chronologic or
what is it chronologically you're 34
biologically you're you're 23 so it said
I was great and then they had this other
score where they look at is it the most
hang on hang on you're 23 biologically
yeah like according to this it's so
which is which is like a false sense I
know Derek just said it's but
I'm not gonna lie kind of admire you for
that but
I just want to open my books but that's
my thing is I see that I'm like oh sick
I'm doing everything great but I'm like
I'm pretty sore though like I don't know
like you know like I don't know if I'm
doing everything perfectly and what's it
called what they look at is it the
methane or uh methylation methylation
they look at that and they're like oh
you're kicking ass your rate of Aging is
super low so I'm like sick like I'm I'm
not gonna change anything but but that's
not exactly the reality because I don't
always feel great you know what I'm
saying I also go went on a kick I've
tested everything so I've tested the
semi uh semi-glue tied I've tested trt I
don't do any of that now and then I use
Anastrozole which is like in my opinion
the worst thing ever I hate that
it made me feel miserable I've tried
Clomid now I don't do anything but I've
gone through I've tried it all because I
I like experimenting with all these
stuff and then I like doing the blood
work it's like an addicting thing it's
like someone who's obsessed with
different gadgets you know what I'm
saying why did you come off of a trt
um because I would so I got like strong
so I like uh I wanted to do it because I
was really low for years like 130 and I
was like all right let's get this right
and figure out what's going on and so I
did it and I got low body fat I got
strong I was hitting like record squat
and bench numbers and then I was like
all right well let's try without it
let's just see what happens if I don't
take it and I still felt great and so I
was like well you know if I don't have
to take it and my testosterone level
actually went down but I still felt
wonderful and I was still lifting
wonderfully and my body felt great so I
was like let's just try not doing it for
a while how long ago did you come off uh
last summer a year a year okay what's
your test now dude it dropped it was 800
and then it went to uh 400 420. you said
it was like 130 or something before you
started to your yeah yeah and I was 26
body fat and I felt miserable I was also
running my company and I was stressed
and I didn't get and and
um for a year I tried eating healthy and
lifting and I just didn't get it right
and then I sold my company so I got
Financial Security I was pretty pretty
ripped I was pretty strong my I got
married and my relationship was awesome
and I just felt happy and I ate well I
ate all natural foods and I just felt
dialed in and then I just went off of it
and my testosterone dropped but I didn't
feel horrible
interesting Well yeah if you don't need
it yeah probably better to wait if you
don't uh want to be how old are you 30.
are you are you on it right now
um yeah but it's for me more so because
when I was younger I did a lot of
Hardcore bodybuilding stuff and shut
down my system and now with what I know
now I could probably restore natural
function similar to what you did but it
would be a lot more aggressive of a
recovery phase and more arduous and
putting myself through that right now
isn't necessarily top of mind so it's
kind of just been a stay on it right now
and optimize everything around it but
yeah that's kind of how I ended up on it
there's there's a few of the things that
I really like though what's it called
the is it BP 157 like some of the bpc
like some of these peptides that like
for example if I strain my achilles and
as I get older I'm like not my my
injuries aren't healing
um which is like the most depressing
thing about age is that you just like
heal slower or like and you get hurt
easier bro you're 23 what do you mean
well that's why those tests are that's
why I'm saying those tests are
they like say that you're young I'm like
I don't know man my shoulder freaking
hurts and it's been hurting for a month
uh and uh like I've been really
interested in some of those recovery
drugs or peptides or whatever you want
to call them
um what do you think about those I think
they can be useful for sure as long as
they're context specific and not
overused because a lot of them are pro
for example bpc is increases something
called veg F expression and it's
pro-angiogenic meaning it will literally
create
it can induce blood flow that
essentially was not present so you could
also have a pro
carcinogenic type proliferative effect
with cancer cell development if you have
existing cancer cells that could be you
know exacerbated so I think some
athletes use it preventatively a bit too
much but in the context where you
actually have an injury there's low
blood flow to it you can actually have a
use case for it I think it's super uh
High utility very valuable product from
my like very amateur point of view I
think that like the semi-glutide and
Metformin and some of these other what's
it called a jlb uh limiter or you know
uh am I using the phrasing correctly
glp1 Agonist yeah like these things that
like limit uh blood spikes or blood
sugar spikes um those seem really
fascinating like they even seem
fascinating to the point of like I think
they can help cure or help alcoholics
not become alcohol or you know get off
alcohol like it like there's some like
weird things about these drugs that they
can do other things and what they are
intended to do and that's super
fascinating to me at the moment but I
know that you were I think you were on
semi-glutite I don't know if you are
anymore yeah I've tested most of the
glp-1 agonists for appetite suppression
and yeah they definitely are of the
available appetite suppressants in the
pharmaceutical world they're probably
the best overall like mechanism and how
they work because previous Nevada was
people just abusing the hell out of
Adderall and Phentermine and crazy
stimulants to shut down their appetite
but it also screws up their heart their
brain I wouldn't say that semi-gloo side
or some of these drugs are risk-free
though and they certainly have uh
question marks around their long-term
use especially in children who are
developing but um yeah I think they have
like a children's dose now don't yeah
yeah yeah I think so we do there's like
an ozympic Juniors yeah which is
up right it's just I would want the
answer to be just eat less but yeah the
thing though is is it are those children
ever going to become optimal without it
and then is the ROI worth it and you
could easily assert that those fat kids
that would have been fat kids regardless
or better off by taking it for sure yeah
so I and I wouldn't say it well
generally that's the answer for anybody
who's overweight of course because there
are certain uh certainly ways to educate
and help people get on the right path
that don't involve drugs and I've seen
plenty of people do great that were
formerly very fat and then end up down a
different life path and are leaning
around and have amazing Lifestyles and
get into a habit and cement it into
their everyday life but I know some kids
are I don't know just might need it for
all we know you did you did this good
thing I mentioned your Europe video and
the interesting thing to me was actually
that you said that you weren't training
that hard and you I think you like
indulged in bread and food like you you
lived like a tourist you know you ate a
lot but you're like I didn't I felt
great because a I was walking a ton and
I don't remember if you said this or if
I read this from somewhere else another
person's experience but you're like the
groceries in food just seemed higher
quality whether that's like involves
like regulation around the FDA and like
certain chemicals are or aren't allowed
um are you buying most your you said you
spend a lot on groceries and you get
high quality stuff are you buying most
of your foods from popular grocery
stores or do you go to do buy it online
from Niche providers or are you going
what are you doing for that I go to a
butcher for bison liver and things of
that nature mostly my Meats but a lot of
the other stuff is local grocery in
Canada there's not a lot of flexibility
unfortunately on quality of uh or just
availability of some of the foods that
you might otherwise buy at higher end
places in the states so as much as I'd
love to have
if I could the highest level of
everything it's uh sourcing is a huge
issue in Canada as absurd as it sounds
like sourcing for like Basic Foods so
yeah it's uh when I can I get you know
the best available but like for example
bison I think is the leanest most
nutrient dense red meat essentially that
you could get and I will buy a ton of
that even though it's you know three
times more expensive than extra lean
ground beef at the grocery store so
that's one example we talked about this
company I don't remember showing if you
said huberman helped uh get it going or
was a was a affiliate way to do it or
whatever yeah man that thing was cool
like I I I ordered a bunch of stuff like
the but I have no idea if I'm getting
sold in the marketing or not but like
the story behind it like they got me
bought it like they got me so bought
into it no I was at a Peter Ortiz place
a couple of weeks ago and I had the
venison sticks or whatever that they
sell and pretty damn good
um and yeah I trust him and his
recommendation so I would imagine it's
all up and up and everything's probably
pretty top tier yeah man I that story
like totally got me bought in I thought
it was a cool business
um okay and I've been watching some of
your videos and it's made me nervous
about just like my food and like the
quality of food and like Whole Foods for
the longest time was like the gold
standard and now I'm like nah man that
still might even be like I it's
it's to the point where I want to start
raising my own animals you know what I
mean or oh yeah it's tough because it's
a lot of people will swear off
supplements and say buy Whole Foods but
then other people will say the whole
foods are the soil is depleted of
nutrients so then you should supplement
but then you know there's uh trying to
know what you're doing can be quite
arduous and uh um sketchy even when
you're trying to optimize even when you
have the financial means it's trying to
even figure out what to spend your money
on can be uh overwhelming at times for
sure well we appreciate you coming on
man I've been a big fan of yours for
years I know Sean has too
um you're I think what's gonna happen is
like in the next four or five years
there's gonna be uh you might have an
exit or there's gonna be some type of
article that review that reveals how big
your Empire is and I think that
um I I think a lot of people are going
to be surprised at some of the outcomes
that you have you know the fact that you
I believe that you can build multiple
billion plus or nine figure companies
off the back of this audience and I
think it's gonna be really cool when
that story finally finally comes out oh
we'll see where it goes I appreciate you
guys having me on and uh being so
patient as I get back into content here
because I know you guys have been trying
to Kieran has been trying to get me on
for a while so I'm glad we were able to
make it happen yeah shout out to him
thanks Karen we appreciate that
right on all right that's it that's the
pod
[Music]
foreign